I'm the dark,
knuckle-dragging,
right-wing,
Republican former governor of the
state of Texas.
Former Republican, Texas governor
and Trump administration Energy
Secretary Rick Perry was
the most surprising speaker at
the 2023 Psychedelics
Science Conference held in Denver
this June.
Some of you are out there going,
"What in the hell
is that dude doing
on this stage?"
Organized by the Multidisciplinary
Association for Psychedelic Studies,
a group that has been pushing for
FDA approval of MDMA
assisted therapy since the late
1980s, the conference was
attended by a reported 13,000
people.
Perry sat down with Reason to
explain why he believes psychedelics
should be legal medicine for
veterans and others suffering from
PTSD, how to allow
more immigrants to come to America
lawfully and why, if
he were ever to take a psychedelic
drug, it would be ibogaine,
a notoriously powerful
substance made from the bark
of an African tree.
Rick Perry, thanks for talking to
Reason.
You as well Nick.
You were speaking at a psychedelic
conference.
What is so important about
psychedelics that have brought
you, a conservative Republican,
to speak to people who
as you said in your opening remarks,
probably were wondering why you were
there?
Yeah, When I got introduced to this,
approximately five years ago,
it was through a young man
who worked with me at the Department
of Energy. At that point in my life,
I was the secretary of energy, and
he was seeing
some of his colleagues in the
special operations world.
This was a former Navy SEAL
who, interestingly today is a
United States congressman who
is very vocal, very supportive
of the use of psychedelics for
post-traumatic stress.
And he's
the one that started
working with me on this.
Me getting comfortable that
Rick Perry and psychedelics
in the same sentence was
even even close
to a reality.
And his
twin brother, Marcus Luttrell,
who was the author of "Lone
Survivor," the book and then the
movie was made about his
experiences.
That brother lived
with us at the governor's mansion
for two-plus years as
we were, my wife
and I were learning about
post-traumatic stress and how
poor our government was in dealing
with this, frankly.
And we were trying to find solutions
to help heal this young man.
And so all of that
collectively through the years
brought me to a comfort level
that.
I'm a results oriented guy.
You know, the process is the
process. I get it.
But what's the result?
And what I've seen over the last
four years in particular,
studying this, talking
to myriad of
young men in this case,
there have been young women that
have gone to Mexico as well.
I've just not had conversations with
any of those.
But these young men who have
put their lives on the line for us,
who have been impacted
through all the different types of
trauma that come with being a war
fighter, that
this treatment,
this medicine works.
And so
I've also, you know,
educated myself about the history of
this and why psychedelics got taken
away from the research
world, from the
citizens at large, from the
standpoint of being a a medicine
that could could work.
So it started to make
a lot of sense to me that,
you know, these are medicines
that were taken away for
political purposes back in the early
seventies and
that we need to
reintegrate, studying
them, do the appropriate things.
But the potential here
is stunningly
positive.
I mean, when you just look and I'll
give you one peek
at Dr.
Rachel Yehuda,
Ph.D., who's working at
the VA
in New York.
I think she has two
studies behind them,
Phase three
that are showing just amazing
results.
Treatment with MDMA, two weeks,
treatment with MDMA. So
three treatments in a month period
of time.
They have classic symptoms,
anxiety, depression,
sleeplessness, suicidal thoughts,
one or all of those.